the losses of infinity war were
devastating but the surviving heroes
aren't giving up without a fight Clint
Barton aka Hawkeye is coming back to
help finish the job in round two
Avengers endgame but this time around
he's bringing a different darker
attitude and perhaps even a whole new
name here's why this overlooked Avenger
will be more important than you think
potential spoilers ahead everything went
wrong at the end of infinity war just
like that half the universe was dead and
dusted including we can assume Clint
Barton's entire family at least that's
what the first trailer for Avengers
endgame seems to want us to think
cutting - Barton in the streets of Japan
while Captain America's voiceover
discusses the family members people lost
the Thanos decimation this Clint looks
like a man with a sunken soul a
murderous mood and nothing left to lose
he's also got a kick-ass Samurai
inspired new outfit with a sword as this
weapon and no arrows in sight if you're
familiar with this whole story in the
comics you know he's probably not going
by Hawkeye anymore that's right folks
it's time to meet a new hero
goodbye Hawkeye hello Ronan well he's
more popularly known as Hawkeye Barton
has taken on other names before
including a brief stint as the size
change in Goliath in the 1960s in 2007
he took up the mantle of another hero in
the pages of the New Avengers adopting
the role of Ronan as Ronan Orton showed
off his combat skills beyond the bow
taking coaching and encouragement he had
previously received from Captain America
and putting it to good use as a more
well-rounded fighter after three years
in the Ronan role he returned to his
Hawkeye roots in 2010 while comics Clint
was in the Ronin Identity
he and the other Avengers faced off
against the new threat the
shape-shifting Scrolls aka why Captain
Marvel punches an old lady in those
trailers in this storyline many
superheroes and their allies turn out to
secretly be Scrolls wearing the faces of
established heroes to further Ana farías
invasion plot Ronan is one of the heroes
who helps beat the threat back
considering the timing we have to wonder
is that what the movie Ronan is up to as
well maybe the Ronan vs. Scrolls and
Japan rumors stem from a casting notice
for endgame which called for actors who
were comfortable wearing facial
prosthetics which could indicate a lot
of things besides an alien scroll
present since this is a comic book movie
we're talking about some online chatter
indicates that Ronan will play a huge
role when it comes to ultimately
defeating
which seems far-fetched considering
Barton's recent absence in the MCU you
can have dinner without me but let's
explore the speculation one reddit based
rumor says that Ronan will be involved
with a plot to build a second Infinity
Gauntlet after creating a second
gauntlet the Avengers will hop through
time to capture different Infinity
stones before Thanos gets his hands on
them something that based on leaked
location photos of past set pieces being
recreated for endgame like the Battle of
New York from the first eventers flick
seems very plausible specifically it's
rumored that Ronan will have a scene in
which he's forced to defend the new
gauntlet from Thanos minions a perfect
opportunity for Ronan to show off his
new skills regardless of whether or not
Clint spends endgame fighting scrolls or
building a new golden glove there's
reason to believe he'll be essential to
setting up the next phase of the MCU
after all and Game is an end of an era
it's like Tony Stark says part of the
journey of Siena for the first time in
series history it's time for a new
generation of young Avengers to take
over and in the comics acai has one heck
of a protege while Clint Barton is
Marvel Comics first Hawkeye he's not the
only one since 2005 Barton has had a
mentor-mentee relationship with a
younger Archer named Kate Bishop an
equally powerful wielder of the bow and
arrow since her first appearance in the
pages of Young Avengers she's popped up
on a wide array of Marvel comics even
headlining her own series starting in
2016 it was reported in October that
Katherine Langford from 13 reasons why
was secretly cast an endgame in an
undisclosed wolf we know what characters
she looks like but whether she'll pick
up the bow as Kate fish up is still yet
to be determined
our thoughts are somewhere between maybe
and probably maybe Clint won't pass on
his Hawkeye mantle an end game after all
there's already a lot going on in this
story but what about what comes after
MCU cosmic reported that a project for
the upcoming Disney Plus streaming
service is being developed for the two
Hawkeye's with a plot centering on Clint
Barton training a successor who could
based on a comics really only BK fish'
in other words we're pretty sure that
Barton is going to survive and game and
while he may retire afterwards he won't
do it without passing on the boat to
another hero one who will likely carry
on his legacy into MCU phase 4 and
beyond it's worth remembering that these
are still just rumors and reports with
nothing official announced but keep an
eye on these developments not only does
it feel pretty believable it also sounds
really really fun